hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game played between Felix Langille
xqc and he Cara Nakamura it was played
on on on one of their streams and well a
lot of you guys have been asking me to
show some of their games so here it is I
took one from exq C's video I will put a
link into it in the description below if
you want to see the entire stream there
are several games he played against
Nakamura there are normal games games
with Queen odds and a lot of different
stuff but before we check out the game I
would just like to invite you to check
out one other video it's a video by
penguin zero titled chest drama I will
put a link to it also in the description
below it will be the first thing you see
so do check it out if you don't know
what what it's about as we're gonna
discuss it a bit after this game so
Felix lung guile
he's a former professional overwatch
player and now he's a full time streamer
one of the bigger streamers and he cars
been streaming a lot with other
streamers lately and getting more and
more of them into chess so in my opinion
it's it's a good thing it's it's a great
thing you know as if for example if
someone is a streams overwatch or or
League of Legends or hearthstone or dota
or pretty much any other game and he
gets like maybe a 10,000 20,000 viewers
per stream and if he for example streams
chess in front of those let's say 10,000
viewers he it's it's enough to interest
let's say 0.001 percent of their viewers
to get more people into the chest
community I think it's a wonderful idea
and well I I definitely welcome it so
this is one of the games like I said do
check out all of them I will put a link
to it in the description below where he
car is basically tutoring xqc on how to
how to improve his chess so xqc opens
with E 4 we have e 6 Hikaru goes for the
fringe defense and now Bishop to c4 so
it's been seen it's not not a new move
or anything we have D 5 Hikaru strikes
in the center and now Bishop to b5 with
check checking if he car will block with
c6 to retreat to the bishop or Bishop to
d7 just blocking where xqc just trades
so
characters captures and here there is
one game in the database were Knights
the c3 was playing but here we have e
capture Sun d5 and it is as a move five
that we have a completely new game so
what's happening here with a capture Sun
d5 by Hikaru and Knight to c3 developing
while attacking so definitely makes
sense Knight BG to f6 Hikaru defends the
pawn and the Queen f3 adding another
attacker to the d5 point he power
defends it with c6 and now d4 making
room to develop the the dark square
Bishop and prepares castling queenside
so Bishop to e7 Hikaru prefers the
Castle kingside and Bishop to e3 now and
both players Castle here so castles and
castles and now as Hikaru mentioned
during the the stream of course whenever
there's an opposite castles of opposite
sides you want to attack your opponent
as soon as possible since you know that
black will be coming at you on the Queen
side you want to start pushing on the
King side as soon as possible so nice to
be six he car wants to bring the knight
over to c4 from there the night will put
a lot of pressure on the position if you
want to kick it away you're gonna have
to play b3 which further weakens the
King then you allow ideas like a Bishop
day three also the Queen can very easily
join the attack and here white should
definitely go for something like King b1
and well start pushing on the King side
as soon as possible
but xqc goes for a four which is pushing
pushing on the wrong side of the board
but it's very it's very instructional
how he cover deals with it so he Carl
goes Knight to c4 immediately makes room
for the Queen to deliver checkmate and
it's also noteworthy that the knight
from c4 guards both of these squares so
the King will not have an escape route
here so g4 he starts pushing on the King
side but now it's a bit too late as that
a4 move was really really time-consuming
too time consuming so Queen to b6 by
Hikaru going for checkmate here and now
you could block would be three but then
Hikaru could just release a queen before
and then put put the same idea in motion
so xqc goes for Knight the b5 instead
giving up a piece to prolong the game
hikaru captures it and now a character
son b5 I'm just grabbing that pawn but
it's only it's only prong prolonging the
game for a little bit we have Queen to
a5 by Hikaru now threatening mate in one
as the D to R square is covered by the
night and now b3 trying to kick away the
night but it still doesn't help since we
already mentioned that the night covers
both of these squares so now quinta a1
will be checkmate but he car does not
deliver checkmate
instead he car goes Queen to a3 check in
order to to further explain the
cooperation between pieces here in this
case the knight and the Queen how they
can deliver this checkmate but also
another one so here a King Tubby one is
the only move which Felix played and now
Queen to be to this shirt mate and there
is nothing more of course Felix can do
here so a very nice sixteen move game
and a very very educational one what
happens when there are castles of
opposite sides how one move that a4 can
just bring whites whole position to a
crumble if you don't if you don't start
pushing when you should bad things will
happen so very very nice game by both of
them and yeah regarding that video I
hope I will now give you a few seconds
to the side if you still haven't seen it
to check out the first link in the
description below it's really not long
but you will have a better idea of
what's happening so now that you've came
back from watching that video and I will
talk a little bit about elitism in chess
now of course there's elitism in chest
chest chest is the ultimate game and
there is no chance in chest there is no
RNG there is no there are no teammates
which you can who you can blame there
are no different environmental
conditions like when you lose you lose
because you lost and there's no one else
to blame but however when you win the
reward is I believe the greatest than in
any game because it's only you who
deserves that that praise so the reward
is yours and yours alone and it's it's
it's normal that there's a lel it isn't
in chess however there's there's too
much of it and it's very unhealthy for
example in this video that i've asked
you to watch in the description below
penguin zero talk
about the incident we've been Feingold
how he called Hikaru some dirty names
and said that he's only bringing more
more people into the chess world for
views like xqc and some other gamers
like box box and voyboy and some other
players from the league community for
example and I've always thought this was
this was a good idea for example I I
learned like maybe two years ago that
boy boy also plays chess and I
immediately made a video on one of his
games where he was simultaneously
playing Yasuo mid and then you know when
he was going back to base when he was
buying when he was returning to lane he
would play some chess moves and I
thought it was very exciting I mean
immediately showed that game because I
saw it as an opportunity to to introduce
chest to other players in the league
community so here it's not much
different and I don't know I really
think it's a good idea but regardless of
what the video in the description below
says about Ben Feingold I've experienced
elitism in chess on myself plenty of
times for example in in real life and on
the Internet as well I remember some
maybe 12 years ago where when we were in
the playing in the creation team
championship and we had the opportunity
of meeting some grandmasters there but
you couldn't really talk to them they
always you know I walked together did
everything together it's like it was it
was like if you're not a grandmaster
you're not even allowed to talk to them
and it was a very elitist I I didn't
enjoy it and I don't think anyone else
did but I also remember when I started
the channel everyone was well not when I
say everyone I mean mostly negative
people we're saying that I have no place
showing showing chess games that I
shouldn't be explaining chess that I
shouldn't be shouldn't be even enjoying
chess publicly online because I'm not
I'm not a very strong player and it's
funny because I
although elitism in chess is
ever-present it's not only present
amongst the elite only among elite
players I've had I've had cases where
even weaker players them than myself
were saying that I shouldn't be like
having YouTube channel I shouldn't be
shown
chess so it's I I do understand where
all of this is coming from and it is
well it's I don't really mind all the
negative comments that I've received on
the subject throughout the years but
someone who is maybe wired differently
you know mentally then myself would
would easily give up on what he's doing
or it would really take a toll at all
and his mental health or I don't know it
wouldn't be it's just it's just bad for
for introducing new players into the the
game of chess and it's also just
terrible for the community so that's why
I've used this quote above the board for
this video it's probably one of my
favorite chess quotes it says chess is a
scene which a gnat may drink and an
elephant elephant may bathe saying that
it doesn't matter how strong you are or
how weak you are
chess is a game for everyone because
everyone can enjoy chess like even if
you just know the rules you can still
enjoy it and you can see this everywhere
you can see this in bars in you know
libraries in you know in the park
pretty much wherever in schools it
doesn't doesn't matter what what level
of what the level of your plane strength
if you if you can enjoy chess then chess
is definitely the game for you and yeah
I think it's it's definitely something
that needs to be addressed and I think I
think we are now on a good path to
addressing it and also I chose calm is
organizing a tournament not just a
tournament but a tournament with a price
font of fifty thousand dollars where
sixteen of the most popular twitch
streamers will compete for the prize
font of $50,000 featuring some streamers
like Nate Hill Yasuo box box and more
and I've seen there was an announcements
the announcement that xqc will also be
joining this tournament so it will be
like I don't know what what's their
playing strength it might be ranging
from 1,000 to maybe 1,600 max I would
say and they will be competing for a
prize fund of $50,000 and these are
extremely popular streamers so it's not
I don't believe for them it's about the
money I do believe they have plenty of
money but it's so many just streamers
from different games will be playing and
streaming chess I think it's a it will
just be a new boom for for chess and it
will but it will enlarge the community
like the like tenfold I think it's gonna
be great for chess and I myself enjoyed
a you know a few games of League when I
was younger and I'm actually very happy
that something like this is taking place
and I I will I'm sure I'm gonna enjoy it
and we're definitely gonna cover some of
the games from from this tournament so
I'm very much looking forward to it and
yeah I mean it doesn't matter what
you're playing strength is if you if you
go online and if you you know go to any
chess platform click click you know
challenge D the match making algorithm
is pretty much the same as in any online
game so if you're if you're rated a
thousand the match making algorithm will
match you with someone of a similar
strength and it doesn't matter how
strong or weak you are there will always
be so many people that can defeat you
but there will be even more players that
you will be able to defeat so you know
chess is a wonderful game try it
enjoy it and you'll see that it's it's
just awesome but yeah yeah that's pretty
much it
what I wanted to say on the subject all
you know now do check out the video in
the description below so you know what I
was talking about if you didn't get the
idea
all right yeah yeah that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it I'm sure Felix
learned a lot by by playing with
Nakamura
so many games and getting getting advice
from an elite Grand Master and Nakamura
is doing doing good work here because
it's ok it's different when someone like
me does it online since I'm not an elite
player but when Nakamura plays with
someone like Felix like box box like boy
boy who someone who is an elite
Grandmaster then that really puts a huge
shadow over elitism in chess and I think
it's III I think it's a wonderful
wonderful thing so
again I do hope you enjoyed it I would
like to thank William William Gould Ryan
boson truck vendor now Paul Saxton and
Ralph Dell Oh for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check -
on my previous video serum thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the Lynn
Doris a be checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chest world so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day and do check out the other
games between Felix and Nakamura the
links are in the description below see
you soon